vous mettez pas la pression pour faire
tout ce qu'il faut comme il faut faites
tout ce que vous pouvez comme vous êtes
reposez-vous la tête reposez-vous le
corps c'est un peu compliqué de moi j'ai
une petite fille qui euh qui atteint du
syndrôme de RET une maladie euh
neurologique très grave 24 ans peut-être
que justement le défi pour vous ça va
être de d'accepter de vous reposer parce
que j'imagine que ça vous demande
beaucoup d'accepter ma femme est au
combat tous les jours moi je suis devant
des caméras et puis donc j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai pas mal de choses à réfléchir moi
je voudrais vous donner un défi vraiment
simple c'est d'accepter joyeusement
d'être là c'est un moment pour vous
prenez-le
vraiment courage à vous merci à tout à
[Musique]
l'heure